aujourd'hui c'est le jour de ma mort
mais je vais faire ce qu'il ya juste
trois balles dans la poitrine et c'est
complètement vidé de son sang il bossait
à 77,6 femme violée par un officier de
police et vous auriez pu éviter ça ça va
faire un scandale seulement si l'info
devient public en fait la chaîne d'info
en clair en ce moment je traque un
suspect pouvez-vous peut couvrir c'est
moi je tombe ce sera vous qui amortirait
ma chute et vous pourrez dire adieu à
votre famille vous savez ce qui est pire
sur un homme et ces dames on arrive
toujours après les faits il est toujours
dehors je peux pas le laisser penser
un bord ce qui va marcher je vous plais
de tout coeur
les gens disent que c'est le destin mais
moi j'ai jamais cru à sa jusqu'à
maintenant